start by seizing the meat well
brisket is a cut of beef from the
breasts it's inexpensive but it's fitful
royalty with long slow cooking place it
into hot casserole dish with a little
olive oil and brown on all sides
[Music]
next make a tasty broth to flavor the
meat into the dish add chopped carrots
celery a whole bulb of garlic cut in
half peppercorns aromatic close and
freshly ground nutmeg
pour in hot water to braise the brisket
[Music]
bring to the boil and cover tightly then
transfer the dish to a low oven and cook
for three to four hours
cook blow and slow the results are
amazing
tender melt in the mouth meat fantastic
with roast potatoes or in sandwiches
with lots of mustard but I like it best
with tangy piccalilli in the oven in
under 10 minutes then all you have to do
is sit back and wait so easy and
absolutely delicious what's not to love
about my succulent beef brisket
we start from the bottom to the top so
there across dinner is making sure this
doesn't turn out dry and is all in the
preparation